Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by 99 designs and ex officio.
99 designs is the world's largest online marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including to get cover concepts for the four hour
body,
which went on to become number one New York Times Number One Wall Street
Journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim,
whether you need a logo,
a car wrap,
a web design and APP,
a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you love or you pay nothing.
It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work week as a resource.
Check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash Tim and if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99 as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions.
So check it out.
Ex-Officio boy,
where do I begin?
I have a long history with ex-officio.
Ex-Officio makes clothing and as far back as 2007 2008 I had a hit video that
went viral called how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less.
And I talked about ex-officio underwear.
Ex-Officio underwear is lightweight,
ultra lightweight,
quick drying and antimicrobial.
Why is this important?
Well,
I've gone through 20 plus countries with two pairs of underwear before,
both from ex-officio,
and I'm not alone in this.
This might sound crazy,
but a lot of executives,
for instance,
we'll take this underwear,
they'll wash it in the sink or somewhere else,
roll it up in a towel,
like a Burrito step on it,
and a few hours later they are completely dry,
completely clean.
You don't have to just have to and yes,
they have to be comfortable for all day wear,
but check out their clothing as well as their underwear.
You can go to ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim that's x,
C I o.com forward slash Tim and you can see this video which has a bunch of
other packing tips,
but this underwear,
this clothing is not just for the gents ladies.
You have choices too and they really have an incredible collection of high
quality products that I've used for almost 10 years now.
So check them out.
EX-OFFICIO DOT com forward slash Tim
walk a walk,
a walk up,
boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to the Tim Ferriss show.
For those of you new to the program.
This is the forum through which I try to dissect excellence to find the tools
and tactics or approaches that you can use.
And that ranges from billionaire investors to chess prodigies to mega platinum
musicians too.
In this episode's case,
comedian,
uh,
a Comedienne,
e n n e,
a n or standup comic,
depending on the terminology that you for Margaret Show,
she has an illustrious career and is a prodigious talent and she is also a
polymath.
She's not only a very celebrated standup comic,
but she's been a fashion designer,
a singer songwriter.
She's been in feature films of course,
and the TV series including sex and the city and 30 rock.
She's been on dancing with the stars and we don't have time to go through all of
her accolades.
But this particular conversation digs into her inspirations,
tricks of the trade,
uh,
different practices that you can borrow a sexuality,
including bisexuality and her topics of choice,
her different challenges,
addiction.
And we also delve deep into the slow carb diet.
So I hope you can indulge me on that particular segment of the program.
But it goes into some nitty gritty details because Margaret had a bunch of
questions.
She's followed it and is a fan of the protocol,
so perhaps it will help some of you out there and as always you can find the
show notes at four hour work,
week.com forward slash podcast for links and further resources.
It's a four hour workweek.com forward slash podcast and we're using a new audio
equipment in this introduction.
So let me know what you think.
Be Very curious to hear your thoughts.
Without further ado,
please meet Margaret Cho.
Hello Ladies and gentlemen,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
I'm very excited for this episode because I have someone that I've admired for a
very long time,
been a fan of for a very long time joining us today and that is Margaret show
are good.
How are you?
I'm doing great.
Thank you very much.
That's wonderful.
Of course I was,
I was having one of my many nights of insomnia,
which I've,
I've dealt with an improved on and that was a sort of scanning through Twitter.
And I came across your profile because I'm a huge comedy fan and I saw also
follows you and my eyes just about popped out of my head.
I was,
uh,
I was so taken aback and reached out and we connected and uh,
and here we are and here we are.
But where we're are we finding you at the moment?
I know you travel a lot.
Um,
today I am in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
There is something,
I'm a big storm outside,
so that's thunder.
But I'm,
I'm,
I'm always on the road.
So,
uh,
that,
that's,
I'm doing the show here today.
Very cool.
And
um,
I know we have some precious time with you before you take off.
It is hard for me to know even where to begin because you've done so many
different things and it seems like lived so many different lives.
You've had television,
books,
film,
obviously the stand up when you meet someone who's unfamiliar with your work
doesn't recognize you.
If they ask you,
what do you do,
how do you even respond to that?
I think I identify mostly as a standup comedian.
And a thank you for your kind words.
I,
I was excited to connect with you too as I'm a big fan and I think,
but comedy is really,
um,
what I would say I do.
I think probably you're the same in that you are quite a multihyphenate in the
different things you write about and the different things you talk about.
And so how would you define yourself?
Suicide.
Would it just be author or would it be
for body expert or we're thinking expert Moby Heisman.
It's are,
are kind of tricky.
Says,
you know,
so as you are an author,
I guess I am a standup comedian,
you know,
that's the basic places to start from.
But there's so much more.
No,
for sure.
It's something that I've,
I've had trouble with for a very long time.
Uh,
it,
depending on who I'm talking to and how badly I want to kill the conversation.
If I think they're just being polite and trying to get through the three or four
cocktail questions so they can glance over my shoulder and move on.
I'll say something like,
you know,
professional dilettantes it comes to mind.
A drug dealer was one I used to use.
Um,
and um,
it turns out it's a great way to get people out of your house at a dinner party
if you will ask them if they want to do heroin or,
you know,
there,
there are a lot of sorts of tricks,
tricks of the trade depending on where you are.
Great at.
That's a great idea.
Now the,
uh,
the,
the standup comedy side of things,
uh,
I,
I've,
I've had the good fortune of,
uh,
occasionally having the chance to chat with people when I've gone to live shows,
for instance.
And I'm always interested to know,
and if,
if you've been asked this question a thousand times,
feel free to answer a different question,
but what compels you to do comedy?
And is it the same now as it was in the beginning?
It's exactly the same.
The what compels me is I need to be heard and I need to make people laugh and
then need to express what I think,
things that need to be said and also to do.
Just have a good time,
you know?
And,
and I've had that impulse.
I think since I was about eight years old,
I,
I've always wanted to be a comedian and,
um,
you know,
it,
it's the impulse to do with that.
The intention,
everything is the same.
It's nothing that's all altered.
And I think this is this,
this is probably the same for most comedians out there.
Um,
there are quite a lot of people who do develop a kind of aversion to it.
After doing it for say,
30 40 years,
they really feel like they need to retire.
But I more on the side of,
I think I need to do it more.
Actually as I get older,
so I'm fortunate in that it just sustains me is that it's the way that I make a
living,
but it's also my social life and,
and a great pastime and a great,
great,
great thing to do.
The,
um,
the aspect of my career that a lot of people ask about his writing and I've,
I've noticed her different breeds of writers.
Uh,
this is,
this is going to come back to the standup question.
What a lot of writers and I would say myself included,
have a com,
have a,
a need almost a therapeutic need to write at points no matter how hard the
process is,
uh,
almost as a way of,
of self medicating and,
and getting neuroses out of their heads.
And then I'm not projecting here,
but this is,
this is for me there.
There are many times when I will,
I will write in the morning and,
uh,
the material I know is pure garbage.
It's just completely self indulgent morning pages,
but it's,
it's my equivalent of taking my psyche and sort of whacking the rug to get the
dust out of it before I move on to my day.
So that I don't have all of the group,
the Gremlins in my head.
And I'm curious if,
uh,
at least in the standup world or the comedy world,
it seems,
it seems that that people have different drives and different things that keep
them going.
And I'd be curious to know if you could comment on what it is for you.
Well,
I think that I had the equivalent of a morning pages sort of thing,
cause I work almost every day.
I mean,
I perform a lust every day.
They're there.
There's different things that I do.
But,
uh,
as a standup comic,
it is really a daily effort.
And so,
you know,
you kind of bone off all of those kind of like ideas that are like late,
late,
late floating on the top,
and then you can get to the real meat of it.
Um,
so I guess I have that kind of a meditation too.
I wish that I had more of that as a writer,
you know,
as an author for me either that's something that I would like to pursue more,
but,
um,
I still don't have the intense need for it that I do.
As a standup comedian.
When did you do your first professional stand up and when did you decide that
you were going to,
uh,
do it professionally?
Oh,
I decided that I was going to do it professionally when I understood that I was
going to become an adult and that one at some point,
you know,
that this would be my job.
And,
and,
and then my,
as soon as I understood what the job of standup comedy was,
then I,
I became very committed to doing it.
And that's it.
I think an unusual thing maybe for somebody to choose the profession at eight
years old.
But I,
I knew that it was actually more than a profession.
It was really,
um,
uh,
kind of a calling.
And then I really started early.
I started during professional performances at 14.
I was touring by 15.
I was making pretty great living by 18.
And then I was on television by 20,
so it was a,
it was a very,
very important thing for me and it was really destiny.
Who were some of those early inspirations and role models for you that,
uh,
that you look to as models if it's,
if that were the case at all and in the very early days,
the main model,
um,
for,
uh,
my early years and then of course pretty much until now was Joan Rivers and
that,
that's been a very difficult,
you know,
right now I'm,
a lot of comedians are feeling the loss of both her and Robin Williams.
And then it's,
it's a really,
it's a terrible time in comedy because it's like we lost our,
the king and Queen,
you know,
and now it's like,
who is the heir apparent?
But mostly it's this sorrow and mourning,
so it's,
it's pretty terrible.
What made,
what made you special?
Obviously she had just an incredible career in longevity and endurance.
I mean,
my God,
but uh,
what,
what was it that of all of the people out there really appealed to you about her
when you were getting started?
I think that she was so on afraid she was so just her fearlessness and she was a
woman and she was,
um,
just so mighty,
you know,
as alive comic,
like the stuff that she would do in clubs and at night,
like not,
you know,
not including like the,
any lows red carpet stuff and the Oscar stuff.
She was so filthy.
I mean,
she was so I need to the very end,
you know,
just the most Raunchy comedian you could even imagine.
And she would shock us,
you know,
the most unshockable people.
He was a incredible,
and,
and also the,
the,
the reason why she and I were close as that,
she really taught me a lot about gratitude.
You know,
she had intense and immense gratitude for everything in our life and wanted me
and all these other comedians that she would foster in a way that she wanted to
instill that in us,
that,
that this was a really magical thing,
this gift that we were given and that we should really grateful for it.
And,
and that's the most valuable lesson I've ever learned from anyone.
So she was really,
um,
combination parent,
like a mother and whatever.
Like Mister Miyagi,
like Pat Marina from karate kid.
Like she,
she was a really,
um,
she was a great mentor and a great woman.
Uh,
I should,
I mean,
it would be really great to have that as a practice to make a gratitude list or
something like that.
But mostly it's just an attitude every day and like,
I'm really happy in what I do.
I really love what I do.
Um,
it's,
it's a really great feeling to do what you love and,
uh,
you know,
for me it's about making money of course,
but that I would still do standup comedy without making anything.
I put just as much effort into every show,
no matter how much they're making or whatever it is.
It's something that I always wanted an eye.
I'm so happy that I get to do it and I think that,
um,
it's just wonderful.
So I don't actually have a practice,
but that might be something nice to implement later
if we're looking at your schedule or your rituals.
Actually,
before we even get to that,
you mentioned fearlessness.
I can imagine that would complete panic into my heart.
More than getting up on stage doing stand up where you really have to,
you really are not going to be given any mercy.
Laughs by most people.
I mean you have to stand on your own merit.
What,
what are some of the,
when of you,
what are some instances where you have been most afraid on stage?
And then I had to figure out how to do shows without having
software and my computer.
And then I also brought people on stage who would
or I would actually ask them out and they would read them.
Um,
so that was helpful.
Well,
but it was really terrifying to not have the capacity to deal with the Heckler,
which I'm very good at.
It's one of my speciality is
the,
this like,
you know,
kind of the immediacy of life performance.
You know,
I took away my spontaneity.
It took away,
um,
just a lot of the,
uh,
kind of freshness and the,
the,
the unpredictability of what life was forming some standup comedy is,
which to me is the greatest part of it.
So that was really terrible.
Um,
and then I've,
you know,
that dad show,
I mean,
I,
I probably have,
uh,
the worst shows that anybody in my category,
you know,
and in,
in the level that I am as a comedian because I'm so committed to taking risks as
a performer,
I can really do terribly.
And sometimes that can be really scary if you're a say in different countries
like in England or Scotland where it is,
there's a high angle you don't do well in comedy and you know that that the iPad
really bad fights and you know,
a couple of instances where I was really scared for a physical harm
because I really,
um,
I give it to people and really let them have it if I'm backed into a corner.
And so,
um,
it's a,
it can be,
it can be really nuts.
People can get really angry.
When you said,
and I'm just paraphrasing here,
but I'd love for you to expand a bit on what you,
what you just mentioned related to sort of having the potential to do worst in
your category or class of,
of comic.
Why do you have sort of higher,
um,
crash and burn potential?
Um,
or what's,
what's the,
uh,
why do you have the added risk factor?
Yes.
I think because I will come off as anything scripted and I will go with the flow
and then I will,
um,
really engage with an audience in a very personal level.
Like I'm not the kind of artists that can go on autopilot,
which actually happens much more than people realize,
right?
Like I don't have,
I don't really have that ability.
So I build it from the ground up and build it from scratch every time from the
beginning.
And so that in itself,
it's a huge risk when you're not necessarily relying on the tried and true and
things that,
you know,
work and you're going into everything when it popular Rasa that you really are,
you plugging into something designed.
But that divinity it's not,
oh,
well is we're human,
right?
So it can be,
does very scary.
Um,
and I think that that's the energy that I thrive off of.
That's what I love,
but that's innately is,
is kind of a risky behavior.
Sure.
Right.
Yeah.
You can be knocking for the Muse and they might not be open for business.
Uh,
uh,
talking about hecklers.
So this,
this,
I would love to dig into a little bit.
What are your favorite ways of dealing with hecklers?
I mean,
is there a,
uh,
sort of,
you know,
Margaret Cho?
Do you have any,
any particular responses?
If you're just like,
you know what,
I don't want to deal with this guy right now.
I need to cut them off at the knees.
What are some of the fastest ways of dealing with,
with hecklers?
And you know,
maybe there are different types of hecklers.
I'm sure there are,
but I'd love to hear a little bit about that.
Well,
there's different types,
but the best thing to do is to really just out now engage somebody and really
try to find out what they're trying to say.
And,
and so there's no like plant nurses set lines or the do scripted idea of what to
say to shut them down.
It's really going deeper and finding out why this person with choosing to
disrupt a conformance that everybody has paid for and that everybody is there
and agreed to sit four.
Why does somebody want to rebel against that?
And,
and so I,
I,
you know,
I'm curious about it and I'll usually give them quite a lot of time.
Like if I have,
uh,
there's,
cause there's a potential to create a whole show around them.
And this is something I learned from,
Oh,
it's great.
I'm Paula Poundstone who's an absolute genius at that.
I mean,
she will,
uh,
he'll do a show and if somebody gets up to go to the bathroom,
she'll go to their chair,
she'll go to their care and she'll take your jacket and put it on and go through
their pocket.
And really just,
I mean,
she is so fearless when it comes to talking to an audience.
And so I learned that from her.
I mean,
doesn't have to detract from your performance.
It can really be an incredible journey that will only be taken one time.
And,
um,
you know,
it's not to encourage actually it shows,
but sometimes it's really inevitable.
So my,
my goal is to just try to take that road as it presents itself.
If it doesn't work,
if that,
usually the only reason it doesn't work as if the person is too drunk,
you can help this happen kicked out.
Right.
So that's a whole nother thing.
No,
it's there.
It's there,
not excessively drunk.
Uh,
what type of question might you ask them or questions if there's like,
oh,
boom,
you know,
and you can tell they're not totally drunk,
they're just being an idiot.
What,
what type of,
what type of question might you ask them or what might you say to them?
Well,
ask,
um,
you know,
why they're yelling out or what the,
what the purpose is of what they need,
you know,
and then I can ask them about who they are.
I can ask the person there with about why they're saying that.
Like,
why are they like that?
Or they like this all the time and he's a special day.
And then I'll get an explanation from the partner or whatever
you got.
And then you can also talk to other people around them,
like people that are seated next to them.
Like what was it like before the show,
but what were they saying and what,
you know,
like what led us to this.
And then somebody from another part of the room will complain about it and then
you go over there and do the same thing.
But it can be very,
very interesting if you just utilize what they're saying and you,
you it into what you're doing.
And then if you have an encyclopedic knowledge of your jokes and therefore,
you know,
you can call on anything that you might have that would be,
would be relevant.
But I love that immediacy.
I think it is really what is great about standup comedy is that there's that
potential to do anything.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
No,
absolutely.
I mean that's,
that's part of part of why I enjoy going to live shows.
It's just,
yeah,
I really don't know how the movie's going to end.
I mean,
you don't,
you have no idea of how things are going to develop.
Uh,
let's see here.
Are there any particular,
I'm just trying to think here.
Uh,
none stand up influences.
So people who are not standup comics who has affected,
and those,
this could be movies,
books,
anything where people,
but outside of the realm of comedy who have impacted how you perform,
how you present,
how you develop your material.
Oh,
I think Madonna is great.
I love Chrissy Hind.
I love a lot of like female rock singers.
Like they,
I am a musician also,
so we get a lot of inspirations and Bjork and um,
you know,
like just music is always really inspiring and,
and you know,
just like the performance style of somebody like Janis Joplin,
I would love to capture as a comedian that would be my ideal if I could eat
comedian that that is the,
what is Janis Joplin at the thing?
Right.
That would be great.
So singers are incredibly influential.
And,
um,
I think it's because a long,
long,
long time ago I,
I happened upon a pet psychic who,
um,
there was it,
I had a dog who I love very much and you know,
she,
it was like this television show about psychic.
So I was doing it.
I,
uh,
I was talking to her and she said that my daughter thought that I was a singer
because dogs don't understand what standup comedy is.
So I thought that was the sweetest.
Okay.
What idea?
He thought I was thinking this,
you know,
it's for him.
It is,
you know,
that's,
uh,
that's really what type of dog
he was dead.
He died,
but he was a big shepherd mix,
like a big,
like fluffy guy that you would get at the pound.
It kind of every dog at one.
But he was at that,
I,
uh,
it,
it makes me think of very,
very early on for me,
uh,
when my first book had just come out in 2007,
I was,
uh,
headed to south by southwest for the first time to give my first real keynote.
And I was extremely nervous.
I was just a sweaty,
nervous mess even days beforehand.
And I had no real way to rehearse in front of people.
So I ended up going to my friend's garage.
He had three Chihuahuas,
have different sizes and I realized that if I focused on presenting to them that
I assume they didn't understand a word,
but if my actual style of presentation was not really dynamic,
they would get bored and walk away.
But if,
if I was,
if I was really animated,
they would sit there kind of bug eyed and look at me.
So I used the Chihuahuas as my test audience for a,
for developing my material for that first now.
Yeah.
And it was a,
it actually worked out extremely well because my,
my tech failed,
my,
my laptop had some type of glitch in the,
the projector wasn't working so I had to go off,
I had to go off script and I had to,
to work without the tech.
Uh,
the,
the question of,
of fearlessness and being nervous on stage,
uh,
you,
you are not shy,
at least as people know you now about talking about race,
gender,
sexuality,
I mean you really cross into all sorts of different worlds that,
that many people I assume would avoid because they're perceived as sensitive
topics.
Uh,
were you ever nervous about broaching those types of subjects early on or have
you for the very get go?
No,
it's a nerve wracking because you know,
you want to have a semblance of privacy and then sometimes when you reveal
things on stage that,
you know,
are pretty,
they can,
it can be kind of weird.
I,
you know,
like I,
I think that,
I think that privacy is really overrated though because it's just a kind of a
social construct that doesn't really mean that much because all human beings
are,
we felt all the same things.
We've had all the same heartbreaks and tragedies and dumb zee was in stupid
things and you know,
we really are not,
no,
none of us are a stranger to that.
If you've lived at all,
you know,
so,
um,
you know,
it's not like anything I say.
It's not like something we haven't,
everybody has itself,
but still things can feel odd and weird.
Um,
but so I was more conscious of it when I was younger,
um,
is that like I'm bisexual and I was really scared of revealing that or maybe the
first 10 years of my career because I was told by my management then that would
be really bad to be gay in any way and that I should not express that.
And so that was a really scary thing because,
you know,
I was in relationships with women and,
and stuff and I had to hide that,
which I'll always felt odd and weird,
um,
that I could have fine relationships with men and show that,
but with women who would somehow wrong and,
and so I,
I really gave up trying to pretend that I was anything but myself very early.
When did you,
when did you make that leap?
What was the,
this the,
the year roughly?
I'm just trying to think of it in terms of the kind of cultural and political
climate.
Uh,
when did you come out,
so to speak?
Publicly?
I think probably about 95,
96 something like dark pretty early.
Yeah,
pretty early on.
But then women are now,
I realized,
and I looked back on women's sexuality,
women's bisexuality is a lot more,
I don't know,
it,
it's a lot more easy to deal with or people have a harder time dealing with men
and male sexuality and fluidity there.
But what's hard is,
um,
women who are just like to just the,
as lesbians,
they think they have a hard time as opposed to women who are bisexual.
There's,
uh,
there's some,
there's some kind of glamor and majesty attached to buy.
Not sure it's true,
but it certainly exists as a kind of a archetype or stereotype even.
Oh,
sure.
I mean,
I think that,
uh,
you know,
even in,
uh,
I live in San Francisco had been there for ages and it's sort of joked that,
you know,
bisexual women no matter what,
which is ridiculous of course.
But,
uh,
you know,
often referred to as Unicorns and,
um,
you know,
I think there's that,
there's that,
uh,
it sort of holds,
occupies a very unique place in the mind space of even a mainstream America for
whatever reason.
Um,
but uh,
yeah.
Have you ever,
uh,
have you ever had a disclosed anything on stage that at least for a period of
time you regretted?
Well,
I think that I,
earlier
I'm working on this show that's really about,
um,
mental illness and addiction,
which is part of the,
the sort of trajectory and the thing that I'm trying to explain,
and I'm talking a lot about prescription pill addiction,
which I had a really bad case in it for.
Um,
I stopped about a year ago,
but before that it had been about five years where I was really having a
problem.
But you know,
it's like one of those things where you know,
that addiction is really strange because it's so deadly and destructive just in
the way that a heroin it,
it shouldn't be,
but you know,
it's prescribed by a doctor and I was actually getting it from my actual doctor
and it was that,
you know,
that there was all of these levels of legitimacy to it,
that and then secrecy as well.
And so disclosing that is very,
it's very weird because you know,
it,
it really shatters a lot of these illusions of,
I don't know,
um,
I,
I'm maturity and,
uh,
you know,
like sanity and stuff.
So,
you know,
that's a whole nother thing.
Like it's,
it's hard to disclose,
but it's also important too because that honesty keeps me not sober because I,
I still drink red wine,
but I think it keeps me,
it saying that I would because it's a really crazy addiction to have.
Yeah.
I think it's a very insidious,
like you mentioned also because it's extremely common even among doctors
themselves,
extremely common,
but it's not talked about nearly as much in detail as you pointed out,
for instance,
uh,
compared to heroin addiction or something like that.
Um,
what type of,
what type of medications,
just out of curiosity.
Oh,
this is weird.
But
which is like hydrocodone cough syrup.
Yup.
That or even to morphine or methadone or anything kind of any opiates like that,
that,
that was really my problem.
Um,
and it was really,
really destructive.
But it's the same time you don't exactly feel high,
so it's almost a cheat.
Like you're actually not really high.
You're just not sick after you get properly addicted to those drugs.
They really are.
No,
they have no use at all.
Um,
as I kind of a high,
they really only serve to keep you from being sick,
which is a bad thing.
Yeah.
Just you need it to get to baseline to not have this physical withdrawal
symptoms.
Speaking personally,
I think I've been very fortunate in a lot of respects of course.
But one is that hydrocodone,
Vicodin,
etc. All make me extremely nauseous.
So the,
all of these sort of opioid derivative drugs make me very,
very sick.
And uh,
I learned that after shoulder surgery I was given all these painkillers and I
couldn't really take any of them because they made me so sick,
which I think is,
is a blessing in disguise and a lot of ways because my likelihood of abusing
those things is very,
very low.
Uh,
do do you find at least within the world of comedy that people tend to,
if they have addictive personalities and I have no idea if addiction is more or
less common in,
in standup comics than the general population.
Of course a lot of the tragedies are highlighted,
uh,
which I think might,
might skew the public perception.
But do people tend to be either addicted to sort of depressants and opiates or
stimulants?
I mean,
do people often end up addicted to both or do they tend to fall on one side or
the other?
Standup comics,
like our job is really to job is really to obsessed on things.
That's what stand up comedy is.
It just obsessing over a topic,
right?
And you just going crazy on some thing and you know,
that's fine in the context of standup comedy,
but it's terrible if you're just living in the world.
And so,
you know,
th the,
the,
the connection with comedy comics being depressed and self destructive and
suicidal,
uh,
it goes with the territory because the job that Denise requires,
that kind of thinking.
So it can be pretty difficult to manage that.
And then if you add drugs on top of that,
you can do really,
really hard.
And then the lifestyle also,
because it's very solitary,
right?
You're traveling all the time,
you're on sweep,
schedule is off.
It's weird.
The jetlag and then also,
um,
press and shows.
So it's a very,
it's a disruptive and very difficult lifestyle,
almost like being in a band.
But you were,
you're not with anybody else.
You're the only one.
So,
you know,
as musicians are very legendary,
known to be very self destructive in the same way,
at least they have a community,
um,
with them on tour,
even if it's just a few guys on a,
on a,
in a van,
you know,
so we don't have that as conduct.
We're just alone and it can be really messy.
Definitely.
And I think that perhaps to a lesser degree,
the see,
you see some,
some very similar symptoms as problems servicing in a lot of writers as well.
Uh,
particularly writers who,
um,
develop a habit of not mean number one,
they're going to be isolated almost by definition.
And that's part of the reason that I'm taking a break from writing books quite
frankly,
is because three,
three years at a stress,
uh,
at three years at a stretch inside your own head is sometimes a scary place to
be.
And,
uh,
particularly those writers who develop a late night writing schedule,
which is something that I have,
I think are more prone to bouts of depression and darkness.
Uh,
and I mean,
of course there's a sort of long history of people like Hemingway who ended up
not,
uh,
at a very,
positive punchline at the end of things.
Yeah.
Personality wise,
do you find that there are certain characteristics that are common among the
people,
the people,
the standup comics who were addicted to stimulants versus depressants?
I mean,
do you find that there's,
you could,
you can kind of guess which people are going to go one way or the other.
I think that people who are really
add,
you know,
we're really kind of scatter brains and their,
their,
their minds are everywhere.
I think that just like hyperactive kids are given Ritalin and Adderall,
I think they're really helped where they tend to crave on stimulants because it
focuses them.
Right.
And,
and then,
um,
I think that people who are pretty focused but depressed and kind of moody,
minor chord,
like down,
down,
we're gazing bummed out.
People are really helped in lifted by opiates because they offered this
injections of endorphins,
which is something that they're either laughing like your serotonin is messed up
or whatever.
They're just not getting it.
And then the positivity that,
or the burst of positivity that an opiate can give you,
of course,
it's just countered by terrible depression,
which is actually worse than your baseline,
makes everything way,
way where,
um,
you know,
they,
I can see why it's that,
that,
that would be attractive.
I mean,
that's what I have,
you know,
I'm kind of,
I have that kind of a down would sort of say I,
I take some effort to look for positivity and also for gratitude,
which is why I'm so grateful for like my own radically new way.
I need it so much.
Sure,
sure.
How did you,
how did you decide,
what was the catalyzing moment that led you to start taking your prescription
drug addiction seriously?
How did,
and then how did,
how did you end up kicking it?
What was,
what did that look like?
Well,
I just really,
uh,
I,
I just really had no idea how much I was taking.
I really had no idea what I would say.
He,
I didn't understand the contra indications.
I could a con the complete like crazy.
Um,
you know,
I think as things I've,
I was doing to myself and then I was taking like all the ambient,
which is another thing which I think is actually very,
very dangerous drugs that,
um,
people,
many,
many people are very dependent on.
But I also have a very,
it's a bit,
I have a bad insomnia problem.
And so,
um,
but that in combination with opiates is a deadly thing.
You know,
my friend Anna Nicole Smith died from that.
And really it was that kind of suicidal behavior of taking so much pills and not
knowing if I would wake up and not really thinking I would wake up.
I think that that was really,
it just became really apparent.
So I just Kinda,
I,
I threw everything away and then,
um,
you and I told everybody in my,
around me,
my circle and I,
you know,
my work and you know,
I was talking about it on stage and I made it very clear that this is a problem
that I was going through.
And I think just making that,
making it not a secret anymore was really what it was all about.
When I wasn't having to hide or talk,
talk,
you know,
if I talked about it then it really resolve the situation.
I fortunately was able to just walk away and I was very sick for a time because
it's the natural,
you know,
that's what happens when you take the drugs.
But um,
afterwards I was much better and I didn't have,
I kind of a need to go fast to it.
R m a sense that this was going to be repeated.
So you know,
it,
it wasn't like I went to rehab and it wasn't like I really sought treatment,
which most people should.
Um,
but I,
I just uh,
was able to escape fortunately.
Well,
the day that you threw out all of your medication,
why that day was there deeper?
Did you scare yourself somehow?
Was there a conversation?
Did you look in the mirror and see something you hadn't noticed before?
But what,
why that day
I just made,
there was so many patches in my memory that I didn't understand why I didn't
remember and I didn't understand.
Like,
I could feel the whatever the generation of my brain,
I can really feel it
sense that I don't think I'm going to get that part of my brain back.
Like I really felt an emptiness,
like a cleared out.
Like I had deleted files that I didn't want to delete and that was so terrible.
You know,
when you just have like a blank space when you should have something there.
And um,
evidence that things that we're not going wrong,
like room service.
I don't know that I ordered and um,
you know,
like weird photos on my phone that I don't know who these people are and why I
have them.
Right.
Um,
and weird sexual situations that were like,
I should not,
or like who,
who,
who am I talking to in this manner that I don't remember even meeting?
Like,
what,
what is going on?
Like all these things at one.
Right.
Um,
and you go,
I have to get out of this.
Like this is really a weird space because it's almost like somebody takes over
your body for you and drives it.
And that's really strange.
No,
I agreed.
And I've seen,
just speaking of Ambien,
Oh,
I've been on trips before with friends where I've seen them come downstairs
after going to sleep,
like the walking dead on Ambien,
go crazy doing all sorts of ridiculous things for hours,
go back to their bed and have no recollection of any of it the next day.
Um,
yeah,
one of my two best friends growing up about,
um,
I'd say a year and a half ago,
uh,
died of an accidental contra indication.
Um,
he was,
he had had a lot of alcohol,
never took any,
never took any illicit drugs,
recreational drugs.
And he was complaining to a buddy of his about a headache and his buddy gave him
a very strong prescription depressant and took it,
never woke up and that was it.
It just took one shot.
So yeah,
people need to take the alcohol interactions really seriously.
Yeah,
that's,
that's amazing.
That's a major,
major problem with alcohol and Ambien.
And also opiates too.
I mean,
the whole thing wrecks your liver,
but on top of that,
uh,
you,
it's a judgment that goes completely out the window.
Like you don't know what you're doing.
If there's something that alcohol does in that,
it just really messes everything up.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
I think it's very important sort of topic to explore for folks.
But to switch gears a little bit because I'm,
I'm constantly impressed with just how prolific you are and has been.
What is,
what does your process look like for developing material?
So let's just say that you've just finished,
uh,
you,
you've just finished a special or you just finished,
he basically aced whatever you'd been working on for the last x period of time
and it's time to,
it's time for you to start over.
You have that feeling.
What does the process look like?
How do you come up with your material?
Usually I'm at the,
uh,
probably involved with the San Francisco actually.
Um,
where I just started it recently.
You know,
I came back to the city and I hung out with old comedian friends.
See,
I haven't seen for awhile.
And you know,
there's a lot of little shows that happened.
There's like the deluxe on Haight street and then there's like,
um,
you know,
a bunch of different kinds of nights that happened usually from like Sunday to
Wednesday,
which is for comedians are days off.
And so that's when I'll start to go to these like little kind of clubs in the
city and work things out.
So I'll like kind of put together just everything new,
you know,
uh,
just add a note that I have and I'll do that and I'll do that in different
cities and out.
And then I'll work them into I larger performances where I,
I will have some like level of prepared material,
but then I'll also work on the new script from anything,
can also improvise where I am and it just grows,
you know,
but usually it's built from a small,
um,
you know,
maybe two or three jokes in it will grow into an hour of comedy that would be
ready.
We'll take about maybe a year to make it really perfect cause I would take it
internationally and make sure that it is great and then I will actually commit
it to either a special or album or something like that.
Did you take it international before you test it on the main stage in the u s is
the,
do you use internationals?
Yeah.
So that's really interesting.
That's the first I've heard of that.
And a,
you know a lot of folks may not realize that even companies like Nike for
instance,
we'll do tons of testing in places like New Zealand,
uh,
smaller English speaking countries to refine the products and marketing and
positioning and everything that they then bring back to the u s but they don't
want to have their debutante ball in the,
in the major leagues.
That's really right.
Why it's great because what's great about going internationally as part of the
joy and perform their audience is just so grateful that you came that they will
give you some scale,
cut you some slack tracing cause you can actually,
um,
what negotiate a,
a,
a of like a nice workshop with them because they,
they're,
they,
they know how far away it is.
They know you don't have to turn there but they,
they know you from whatever different things and they so glad that you're there.
So for me it's,
it's a great,
great thing and it's not something that a lot of comedians from America do.
Um,
so I for some reason have the ability to travel and I get to do many,
many countries in Europe except the only country that have done shows in our,
like Italy and Spain,
which it just gets the market.
It's very different there.
But um,
every place that place also has been really fantastic.
And,
and Australia also,
I had to cancel a New Zealand tour cause I've,
I've got it,
it was doing like a TV show.
But I definitely look forward to going back there.
But international markets are really wonderful for me to work out what I want to
do in the future.
What,
what makes Spain and Italy so different?
I'm very curious.
I think because of the Catholicism.
Yeah.
I vote for Lyndon to talk about sex in the way that I do.
Right.
You know,
I,
I very,
very,
um,
like there's this,
this is a joke that I'm telling you.
I don't even know if I should tell this joke,
but I,
it's just,
I haven't had sex in a really long time.
Not a really long time,
but I was upset because Robin Williams died and Joan Rivers died and I can't,
I couldn't,
I don't want to be now.
And I just did it feel like,
um,
so I was out to dinner in San Francisco,
not long ago,
and I was with two gay guys,
which is my way.
I love gay men with these guys I love were at the house of prime rib,
which is,
yeah,
I know exactly what
good.
It's really good.
And we're eating and then the Somali,
Yay.
So cute.
You know,
I'm talking to him and then I thought he was so adorable.
And then he's really young too.
And we laughed.
And um,
then my friends are like,
well,
you know,
they're trying to encourage me.
Like he was just talked to him cause he really like you.
I was like,
oh,
he's too young.
And I know one of them went back and gave the guy my phone number and I was
like,
whatever.
And then so anyway,
I went back to my hotel and it was like one in the morning and the guy actually
called me,
which was amazing.
I thought it was so brave.
So he came over and it wasn't what
it was like a therapy dog.
I don't think you can tell that too.
And it's not a joke,
it's two story,
but another,
you could tell that European,
Italy,
we can tell that joke in Spain without some kind of repercussions of people
getting really angry.
Like,
what are you doing?
Like can you just do that?
You know,
I'm 45 year old woman.
I,
I'm really,
you know,
right.
He was much younger than me.
I really should have had sex with his father,
but it was really what I needed,
given the intensity of porn that comes out of Italy.
Not that I would know anything
that they would be so judgemental to people on the stage,
but I guess there's the public facing laughing and then there's the private porn
viewing.
And maybe those are two different mentalities.
I think it's hard for American comics just in general,
but especially somebody that's really brash and talking about sexuality and
it's kind of
for that.
So those markets has always been a little bit,
which markets on the flip side,
which countries respond best to the sex talk and everything else?
Sweden.
France is incredible.
Germany is probably the best.
Uh,
definitely Norway,
it's amazing.
All of Scandinavia is so down with that,
you know,
they're so excited.
Denmark is incredible.
Uh,
traditionally been very,
very sex positive,
know their history in corn.
It's pretty amazing.
So that's a great place to go to.
But um,
a lot of like kind of sort of northern
Germany,
the ultimate place because there's so much kind of liberal thought.
They're so much a kind of ease about sexuality there.
That is really amazing.
Yeah.
I'm glad you mentioned Denmark.
This is my people
courtesy of my Danish genetics.
I didn't get the height though.
I got the,
uh,
the,
the gigantic head pats square Bob or whatever his name without the,
without the height.
Uh,
to jump to a different type of question.
Um,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
Steve Jobs
and also
the visionary that became kind of legendary
beyond humans.
Um,
so I think that would be my definition of success is somebody that sort of like
crosses a line,
uh,
from like,
here's this to art too.
I don't even know what that is.
You know,
that kind of visionary.
It's pretty profound.
Do you,
do you feel successful?
I think a lot of people would consider you successful.
Do you feel to successful yourself?
Oh,
absolutely.
I know that I am,
you know,
I'm very grateful for that and I know that that,
um,
and achievement,
uh,
there's much,
much higher levels of success I would like to achieve.
But then,
you know,
uh,
I'm no slouch,
especially because I'm probably like,
here is the one who was sustained at the longest.
You know,
that,
that I have been pretty active and out there,
you know,
very,
very visibly for the last 20 years.
And so that's a good thing.
Yeah.
It's hard to make,
it's hard to string it together for that long for sure.
Yeah.
If,
um,
if you could change or improve one thing about yourself,
what would that be?
Oh,
well I would like to have a lower percentage of body fat,
which is why mt four hour body.
Well,
I went.
Wow.
Awesome.
Well,
you know,
you mentioned before we started recording that you had some,
uh,
some,
some food questions.
I'm happy to answer those obviously.
Well,
when you talk about your cheat day,
I almost dread mine because I am physically sick.
Every time I over that,
I've been eating now and the four hour body four very religiously now for about
maybe several months,
four or five months.
And it's a big difference.
But I try to go for the free day,
the cheat day,
and I dread it.
Like I'm afraid of it.
It doesn't feel good to me because it,
any kind of flour or,
um,
excessive amounts of sugar or anything,
they taste so good,
but they don't feel good in my body.
And I wonder if there's a way to manage,
um,
I have a better suggestion during that time.
It's,
um,
but it just doesn't,
it doesn't feel good to me.
Sure.
No,
I can comment on that.
The,
so the cheat day is designed to do a few things.
The first is based on the assumption that people are going to cheat no matter
what and you can contain the damage if you schedule it in advance.
So that's sort of principle number one.
Principle number two is that by spiking chloric intake once a week,
you can help to prevent a lot of kind of downgrading of the metabolism,
whether that's thyroid or otherwise.
Uh,
there are,
uh,
there are people out there who say,
for instance,
while I'm only gonna have one cheat meal instead of a cheat day to,
to limit the damage that I do,
uh,
I only recommend that to people if that means they won't succumb to cravings
later in the week.
So by being disgusted once a week,
it's not mandatory.
Typically what happens is exactly what you're describing.
So people start to dread over doing it on cheat day and they naturally start to
dial it back a little bit.
Uh,
and in the beginning when people are most likely to quit any diet in the first
two to three weeks,
that cheat day is so overdone.
They're dis just so disgusted the,
that that evening and the following day,
they can't wait to get back to a cleaner type of eating because they just feel
better.
Uh,
there are ways to cheat,
so to speak,
to s to spike the caloric intake without having some of the digestive issues,
if that is a problem for a lot of people,
for a lot of people,
that means simply avoiding gluten among other things.
So,
for instance,
if I am training for athletics or I know that I have to have a lot of work done,
uh,
on a,
on a Sunday or a Monday,
just the day after a cheat day,
uh,
I will focus on say carbs or carb rich foods like sweet potatoes or brown rice
or even white rice as opposed to getting it from wheat flour.
Um,
things of that type that or I know going to just put up,
put up a huge fight going through my digestive track.
So there,
there are definitely ways to do it,
um,
and minimize some of the discomfort while still checking the boxes that prevent
you from cheating later.
Another,
another recommendation is that you can make the first meal of the day a slow
carb compliant meal.
Uh,
and a very easy way to do that is to,
um,
just this,
for instance,
you could have a small amount of lentils out of a can.
I mean literally,
this is something I'll do oftentimes is I will have in there,
there are a lot of reasons for this,
but the fiber and uh,
which is important for kind of Gut Flora and,
uh,
bacterial balance in the Gi track.
You could have just spoon out of a can literally,
uh,
lentils in the morning with maybe one or two eggs and that will,
that will naturally inhibit your appetite,
uh,
later in the day.
So you'll be able to cheat,
but you'll be less prone to put,
you know,
to ingesting the last 2000 calories of rocky road ice cream with snickers on top
or whatever.
Because it's usually,
I think for a lot of people,
they do cheat day.
They get to a point where they're like,
Holy Shit,
I am about to explode.
And they look at the clock and they're like,
but it's 10 o'clock.
I have two more hours to go.
I can't,
I can't let cheat day.
And without giving it one last hurrah.
And it's just,
it's,
it's that last extra serving or that last Guinness or whatever that just takes
them from about to explode to just complete insulin coma.
Um,
so the,
the,
the slow carb meal early in the day can help the grapefruit juice plus caffeine
early in the day because of the engine in and all of that can also help,
uh,
because it will stabilize somewhat your blood sugar and your insulin response.
Um,
so those are,
those are a few recommendations.
There are lots of ways to customize cheat day,
but the most important,
I think the most important thing to realize about cheat days that you should
not,
you should not feel like you are,
um,
restricting yourself on she did.
That's the most important thing.
So some people will try to do a healthy cheat day,
but then they have a to eat list of all these things that they don't want to
give up and they end up cheating on a Wednesday night or a Thursday night.
And like most people who do that,
they say,
oh,
fuck it.
I already had one cookie I'm going to have,
now I'm going to have the rest of all these girl scout cookies because I already
fucked up.
And then they bet then they backslide and they don't stick with it.
So as long as you do,
as long as you don't feel like you are,
um,
you have secret cravings that you're not satisfying during cheat day,
you can pretty much do whatever you want.
Well,
what's interesting about the Diet or just the way it is in my body and do what?
I don't have any cravings,
but I just don't,
I don't actually care.
I do the cheat day because it's tastes good,
but it's not because I had a craving,
you know,
it's out to just do it because it's going to help my health,
my overall process,
which is I think I can get it.
That's what's the best thing about it for me is that I don't have that need for
pasta or bread that I did before,
although it still tastes really good when they have it.
Um,
that's just the needs where they,
you know,
the things that you think you can't do left before he started and then you
started and then your idea about food changes.
Yep.
Yeah,
definitely.
And,
and it's,
it's very much a combination of biochemistry and psychology,
right?
I mean,
you have a certain shift where I think the,
the biochemical changes in the physiological changes proceed the psychological
realization that you don't need certain things.
So you have a certain chemical dependency,
just like getting off of prescription medications.
You have a certain chemical dependency which could be related to,
um,
the types of refined carbohydrates that people are accustomed to eating for
breakfast,
which sets the stage for the rest of the day and makes them fall asleep at one
30 or 2:00 PM.
But when you start,
when you start to add in the protein,
the fat and fiber,
then those type of dramatic,
uh,
glucose swings start to level out.
And as you're sort of like,
uh,
your pancreas becomes resensitized,
or at least you develop some degree of insulin sensitivity.
Again,
your body stops having to work so hard and it prevents a lot of the
rollercoasters and then like you said,
about a week into it,
two weeks into it you're like,
wow,
I don't crave those foods.
I thought I would crave forever.
And um,
yeah,
it's,
it's really fascinating.
And the entire diet is really designed to have the highest compliance rate
possible.
And I think this is sometimes lost on say a Paleo or Vegan purists who want,
want everyone to convert to a very inconvenient diet on day one.
And my point is the,
the good program you follow is better than the perfect program that you quit.
And the slow carb diet is a great gateway drug in a positive sense for getting
people to eliminate the vast amount of garbage that they consume.
So,
right,
right.
Yeah,
that's how I think
it's really very helpful.
I think the strangest thing that instead,
I'm really not hungry.
Weird thing cause I was like starving all the time and I'm like,
why do I,
I mean obviously there's reasons why,
but it's like I don't have that.
If I,
I,
I just don't,
I'm never really hungry ever.
Even when I haven't eaten for several hours and it somehow sustains my sits
down,
it just burns.
Yeah.
And I'm not desperate for food.
It's a,
it's a really cool,
um,
I think for a lot of people,
a very cool realization of self sufficiency that,
that,
that uh,
the people do not experience hunger in the same way.
It becomes a very different experience.
And,
uh,
get a part of that is you're using things like cheat day and you're using in
some cases supplements,
but not certainly not necessary at all to change how,
how your,
your,
your brain and your body,
um,
produce and respond to hormones like Ghrelin and all sorts of other things.
And uh,
what's,
what's really cool about it,
a read.
And recently I did a,
I did a seven day water fast,
so I went seven days with nothing besides water with no supplementation,
no electrolytes known anything.
And because of the indirect training of the slow carb Diet and,
uh,
effectively readying my system for that type of experience,
it really wasn't terribly difficult.
And I'm not recommending anyone do that without medical supervision,
but the,
the,
the body becomes a very,
very resilient.
And,
uh,
the,
one of the questions that I get before people start things in the,
in the four hour body,
particularly the slow carb diet,
is what do I eat for snacks?
And my answer,
my answer is,
if you're eating enough and you should be eating enough at your meals,
you're not going to be hungry.
You don't need snacks.
And,
and,
um,
and typically what people realize is that the snacking is a compulsive,
habitual behavior.
It's not because they are hungry,
right.
They're,
they're,
they're basically feeding their pancreas,
not their stomach,
if that makes sense.
Because their insulin response is so out of whack.
And once you fix that,
it's like,
oh,
I want to have a bowl of fill in the blank crap next to my computer because
that's my habit,
but I'm not actually hungry.
Right.
And then it puts into question,
what is food for anyway.
Right.
You know,
like there,
there isn't,
you know,
the cool thing.
Yeah.
And,
and my,
uh,
you know,
at one of the ways to modify a cheat day so that it's,
it's,
it's a more rewarding and less disgusting.
Although I think that that getting people to the,
Oh my God,
I'm so disgusted with myself.
Point is actually very valuable and the first few weeks,
but when you graduate from that,
you're like,
okay,
I've covered the,
I'm disgusted with myself a checkbox.
Like I want to be more functional.
Uh,
towards the latter third of my cheat day,
uh,
you,
you can start to set rules for yourself such as,
you know,
the food,
the food either has to be really good for me or it has to be fucking delicious.
And the,
the fucking delicious part is important because people on cheat day,
we'll often just shovel whatever shitty food is in front of them or around them
right into their mall.
And it gets really gross.
So when you,
and I would say,
you know the,
in the same way that you're looking for a high quality,
if you choose to eat meat and I eat meat that you,
you choose to try to find high quality meat,
right?
So if I'm sitting in San Francisco,
I'm going to look for grass fed beef.
I'm going to look for so on and so forth.
Similarly,
if you're cheating,
you can do the same thing and you can say,
all right,
I'm going to have pasta,
but I want pasta made from fresh ingredients from that,
that,
that does.
I'm going to go to,
you know,
flour and water and this is just a restaurant in San Francisco and I'm going to
get pasta there,
or I want ice cream and I want high quality ice cream.
I'm not just going to go to Safeway and eat five gallons of the cheapest crap I
can find.
You know,
I'm going to go to buy right or whatever.
And it might,
it might be a little bit more expensive,
but I'm going to get higher quality raw ingredients.
I'm going to have cheat meals,
but I'm going to have less,
fewer
preservatives and artificial sweeteners and all that shit.
Um,
so there are definitely ways to make your cheat day a little more regal.
Yeah,
that's better.
it really is.
Then it's a real tree and a real luxury.
But you know,
like I've avoided my last couple of cheat days cause it just really made me
sick.
And you know,
um,
the foods were wearing reminds me a bit of,
when you go to overeaters anonymous,
there's a very specific,
there's two sets,
kind of sex Ed.
Overeaters anonymous is one is called POW and one's called the Cambridge group
where it's just a food plan that you cannot deviate from it.
You just can never deviate from.
But this gay people a lot of freedom from the addictive properties of eating.
And um,
so we know in a sense it reminds me of that and that like now that the food is
out of the way,
the assessing about food is out of the way.
Now I can actually like live my life,
which I think is really the wonderful thing.
No,
I mean,
and that makes me,
I mean that makes my day,
it makes my week just to hear that it's,
it's,
it's a liberating point for people to reach.
And what I've found is that a lot of behavioral,
a lot of systems of behavioral change,
uh,
that have existed for many decades are completely just scientifically off base.
They haven't really been tested.
So the idea that you can take someone who's accustomed to eating a horrible diet
and put them on a strict vegetarian diet and they're going to adhere to that,
it will have less than 10% success rate.
You can't start there.
It's very difficult.
And if you want,
if you want 500 out of a thousand people to succeed instead of a hundred out of
a thousand,
then you provide them with sort of a graduated approach.
And I think there's,
I think there is an incredible tactical application of excess,
right?
So people will say,
well,
everything in moderation.
I'm like,
actually,
I don't think that humans are good at moderation.
So that's why it's easier to go a month without alcohol then having one drink a
day.
If you're an alcoholic,
it's,
I actually eat at the end.
Um,
I,
there,
there are many examples of this,
but my,
you know,
my,
my mom was cured of smoking at one point because her,
her parents,
and I'm not saying this is a great in general parenting approach,
but they said to all the siblings,
they said,
oh,
I found out that one of you likes to smoke.
Well,
here's a box of cigars and a,
you guys can have all of the cigars and when you're done,
then you can come upstairs and,
and then they did not touch anything for a very,
very,
very long time.
And again,
not,
not recommending that very old school,
but in the psychologically,
the cheat day for the first two or three weeks is it is achieving something very
similar.
Uh,
yeah.
So I mean,
I'm,
I'm thrilled that,
um,
that you've been,
been with it for a few months,
obviously.
I'm always happy to,
to answer questions.
I never get tired of talking about this stuff.
Unlike email,
autoresponders and all that stuff from the first book,
which kind of bores me to tears at this point.
The physiological stuff is so rewarding
because it's,
it's a tangible,
visible results.
Right.
And,
and,
and when people go on it,
I mean,
you do get immediate feedback.
Um,
and it's,
yeah,
it's really,
really awesome.
And for those,
for those,
uh,
this is particularly true for certain nationalities,
and I mean,
there's obviously genetic differences,
but for a lot of women out there who might get discouraged early on,
um,
part of the reason for the first say 10 to 14 that some women in particular do
not see a dramatic weight change on the scale is because they're increasing
their protein intake and they're actually losing a lot of visceral fat,
number one.
So organ fat and number two,
putting on muscle,
uh,
which is a,
which is a very positive thing and almost every case.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah.
And then they start to see the,
the subcutaneous fat that,
you know,
the fat under the skin,
which is more visible in the mirror,
obviously,
uh,
start to drop off in sort of weeks.
Uh,
two and three,
and that's why it's so important,
uh,
I think for a lot of people to,
to really take stock of how they feel.
Like you noticed the impulse,
a sort of the,
uh,
the desire to,
to the,
the Ha,
the unnecessary hunger going away to take,
to take note of those things.
Uh,
and instead of looking at the scale,
because it's such a blunt instrument and it can be very misleading.
So those are the
wait myself,
I know I can see the changes in the way that my clothes are fitting differently.
I'm wearing much more smaller sizes and I can tell in a way that my,
the,
just the way that I look and I don't really need to see it.
I know that when my exercise,
while I'm exercising more,
that it's definitely a much more visible.
But,
uh,
and also when I'm Blake,
they're laying off and sometimes I'll get lazy and I'll just eat like beef jerky
or something like that,
which is not the fastest of all this stuff in it.
But you know that there,
there's like when I,
when I really take the time to make,
make my own food and stuff,
that's when I can really see a huge difference.
Um,
it's,
it's that when I get lazy,
like,
do you know there's like the salad dressings and stuff like that,
which probably have hidden sugar and that,
you know,
I,
I can definitely backslide there,
but not that much.
Either.
You're not eating anything that was in breading or anything like that,
you know,
or like sausage with flour,
then that's not too bad.
But it can be really,
um,
you can't,
you can actually have pretty luxurious time eating on,
on program.
Not even,
I'm on a cheat day.
Oh,
definitely.
And most people,
if I go out to a meal with almost anyone at any restaurant,
they never ask me about my diet because they don't realize that I'm even on a
diet.
Generally.
It's very,
and,
and I would say to people out there also who,
who are thinking of going on any type of diet.
And here's the thing,
even if you're not on a diet,
you're on a diet.
I mean diet is really in the scientific sense,
just the,
the food that you habitually consumed.
So you're on a diet one or the other.
Uh,
but you have to rig the game in the beginning so that you can win,
right.
At least for the first few weeks.
And so for instance,
I would like to say that I'm a,
you know,
whipping up a food network worthy every meal and just,
slicing and dicing and it's,
you know,
it's a,
it's worthy of recording for posterity,
but it's not,
I'm lazy like everybody else.
And so if you were to look in my refrigerator right now,
literally I have,
I have single serve Guacamole and single serve black bean hummus from I think
Bj's or one of these discount clubs.
I've got like leftover chicken wrapped up in some plastic foil and a handful of
other things.
And then I have a few supplements that are on hand,
like glutamine and whatnot.
So that I do,
I've done no cooking today and I'm not hungry.
Uh,
that's totally okay.
It's totally okay.
I have,
there are other,
I,
there are readers who have literally I kid you not a last,
you know,
50 to a hundred pounds and the only beans that they consume,
and you don't have to eat a ton of beans,
but they only beans they've consumed or refried beans
eight does it,
he doesn't have to be fancy.
So,
um,
in any case,
I am,
uh,
I'm,
I'm thrilled that you're,
that you're making progress and obviously I'm happy to help anytime,
but let me,
let me ask you on the meal side of things,
so if you had your,
your last meal,
Oh,
you know,
you're,
you're on death row.
What are you going to go out with?
What's,
what's your last meal?
I think I would,
I would really want them as,
uh,
the far follower with a South San and vodka,
you know,
the,
or the petty Elebond k that's my favorite.
Um,
standard and vodka and cream sauce with the talks is so good.
And,
uh,
so that's probably that.
And then maybe some kind of the bread thing,
not,
that's so many suites I guess.
Maybe a little,
but I don't really,
I don't know the is the duck thing,
but you know,
again,
it's like I don't really,
I don't crave it.
Like I used to,
like I used to have to have it once a day at least like pasta salad or you know,
some kind of big breakfast pasta.
Oh,
that's so,
you know,
breakfast offset.
But I mean,
it's like so weird how I just don't have an,
I don't know why he,
I don't even care.
You know?
It's just really weird.
It's crazy.
It's crazy one that,
yeah.
When that type of shift happens,
uh,
do you have a favorite curse word?
Is there any one sort of a curse word or insulting?
You're like,
God,
I love it.
Just,
it rolls off the tongue.
This is really,
this is really a keeper for me.
It just resonates.
Oh fuck.
But that's one that I think I used the mall.
We just probably,
um,
the one that everybody uses the most.
I think
it's good.
It's a very flexible word.
They know it can,
it can,
it,
it can take many different forms.
I think that's part of why it's so useful.
Yeah.
It's like positive and negative and then it can be romantic,
which is really funny.
He actually liked the most romantic thing that you can say and
weird.
Like it could be really horrible thing.
You can say I'm to put the best way to,
so I really love the user friendly quality of the word.
Just fuck.
There's a,
there's a wonderful little book called the,
uh,
English as a second fucking language and it talks about all of the uses of the
word fuck because you think about it,
it's actually very,
very particular,
right?
Because you can say that's,
that's a fucking incredible,
that's a,
but you can't say that I got,
it's in credit.
Fucking bull.
Like you,
there are ways,
very specific ways that you can use it or not use it.
That's unbelievable.
Fucking bold.
Nah,
it doesn't really work.
Right.
So you,
uh,
you really have to,
you've,
you've sort of developed a fluency at a certain point as a native English
speaker with that word.
I find the Australians are,
are uh,
really fond of it.
Um,
but yeah,
just an observation,
right word.
It's my favorite.
Yeah,
a good one.
So if you could,
uh,
I want to be,
I know you have a show king coming up and uh,
that,
that you probably want to do some prep for that.
Uh,
speaking of which,
uh,
just a few more questions,
but if you look at your best performances in the say hour before you go on
stage,
what are the commonalities?
Like what,
what gets you in the zone?
What,
what rituals or routines do you have?
Usually it's just a nice meal.
Sometimes I'll have a book,
sometimes I'll just be reading backstage,
which is a really nice thing to do.
Um,
sometimes it's very busy,
you know,
you can never really predict that there is no,
I have to perform so much that there's no way that I can regulate that hour
before it.
Cause it's always a different situation,
you know,
different cities or different social situations,
different social setting.
I'm coming from something else.
So there's really no way to gauge,
but I like to have,
you know,
sometimes a bit of wine,
a red wine.
Any,
any particular type of any particular type of red wine.
I like that.
Something like that.
A Shiraz,
Shiraz probably or a Malbeck.
Oh yeah.
Dry.
Not Sweet.
Um,
just something kind of pilot.
That's a very hard to Harkey but flavorful but not like juice,
like a red,
like a grape juice,
like very,
very
intense swine that,
that'd be nice.
If you're able to read what type of book would,
uh,
would you choose?
Oh,
I love biographies.
And um,
so I'm reading right now how to be a movie star,
which is like all about Elizabeth Taylor.
I think it's really fascinating.
Um,
I love movie star biographies and the way that Hollywood was like two people
like Liberace and um,
Elizabeth Taylor and you know,
these kinds of figures who were very flamboyant and symbolic at the time,
but led pretty tortured lives too.
So that can be is really interesting.
So I like that kind of stuff.
Do you know people who are
operating at the higher level in Hollywood who are not tortured?
It just seems like it's a tortured town in a lot of ways,
but are there,
are there people who come to mind who are very successful in some capacity in
Hollywood who are not tortured and if so,
why are they not tortured?
How about,
I don't know.
I think that there is a high level a of people who are touching the Gen.
There's also a lot of uh,
uh,
when,
you know,
a lot of people who have done taking taken measures to help them sounds like
through whether it's through sobriety or some kind of program or even some kind
of a religion that makes things a little bit better.
Um,
but I do see happiness out there.
You know,
I do see a lot of joy in regards to your work,
but you know,
sometimes the more brilliant somebody is,
the more crazy they are too.
So we don't really have a really good handle on people is realize.
Um,
the most well adjusted person,
the nicest and well that was just an end famous and successful,
uh,
was probably Dave Grohl from the foo fighters.
He is the most sunny individual I've ever met and so generous and times and
really one of the most fantastic artists all time.
Oh,
so incredible.
Yeah.
Just phenomenal.
What do you think that,
that,
that uh,
why do you think he is that way?
Because of course,
I mean he's seen some dark things,
no doubt,
very dark things.
Uh,
I think he allows himself to just be,
you know,
and I think that part of it is also drummers tend to be very positive people and
I think it is the physical activity.
I think you did that high intensity interval training that is drumming.
Yeah.
That's a great observation.
I never really thought of it that way,
but that,
that actually makes perfect sense to me.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I need to get
positive.
Yeah.
Did a drum set.
I need to,
why have some hand drums?
I got to tell you,
it's like the difference between a day of even 10 minutes of drumming in a day
of no drumming is very,
very,
um,
stark.
I mean it's,
it is,
I think the physical movement and using the hands for something other than
pecking at a keyboard.
A for sure.
So,
yeah.
So on that note,
I'll let you,
I'll let you get off the phone,
but where can people find more from you,
learn more about you,
where can people check out what you're up to?
Well,
my website is Margaret cho.com,
and that's where all my tour dates are.
I have some blog,
blog stuff up there.
I had a kind of everything,
photos and you know,
just to like kind of an overview of what I do.
And then I have,
um,
I'm on Twitter at Margaret Cho and I'm on Facebook at Margaret Cho and,
that's,
I do a bit of Instagram.
It's Margaret Underscore Cho.
Uh,
but yeah,
that's,
that's all my stuff and I'm very active,
uh,
everywhere there,
you know,
I really enjoyed that too.
So,
um,
you know,
I get a lot,
it's funny how much easier life is when you can verify people
on Twitter.
Yeah,
definitely.
Oh,
you know,
it's like,
oh yeah,
it really is that versus like,
it's like you could really see them,
so makes life much easier.
Yeah,
it certainly does.
Thank you so much for making the time.
Hopefully next time you're in ss,
uh,
we can share a glass or two or three of wine.
I would love to test to a four hour body,
which is,
you know,
you,
you will see me and I think that you will be really excited because you from my
photographs from like stuff that I've done,
you then really tell the difference and I haven't had like a photo shoot or
anything,
so I look forward to that so that you can see what things have been done.
You know,
it's also given me a lot,
it made me feel a lot younger too,
which I appreciate.
Awesome.
Yeah,
my pleasure.
Thank you for putting the words into action.
I just write it,
write a bunch of stuff down on a couple of pages,
but it really makes my entire week and uh,
we can decide whether it's going to be a cheat meal or a or standard compliant
slow carb meal.
But either way we'd love to,
we'd love to join you for a bite or drink.
And uh,
thank you so much for the time.
So I'll let you get ready for your Gig.
Everybody a checkout,
Margaret Online and I'll put a bunch of links in the show notes as well.
And until next time,
thank you so much for being here.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for all things graphic design related,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mock up,
some drafts of the book cover for the four hour body ex-officio ex officio and I
go way back ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you can see the clothing that
I've used for traveling through 20 plus countries,
including the underwear,
by the way,
that's about half of my underwear drawer,
right ex-officio dot com forward slash Tim you can also see the viral video that
I put out,
which shows you how to travel the world with 10 pounds or less.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well as every other episode by going to four
hour workweek.com forward slash podcast spell it all out or you can go to four
hour workweek.com and just click on podcast feedback.
If you have feedback.
I would love your thoughts,
anything at all,
who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter at t Ferris.
That's twitter.com forward slash t,
F,
e R,
r,
I s,
s or on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's.
And until next time,
thank you for listening,
okay.
Okay.